that and go as we uh mentioned earlier
to one of the most senior
legal officials in the u.s this is
attorney general merrick garland of the
department of justice in the southern
district of florida to unseal a search
warrant and property receipt
relating to a court approved search that
the fbi conducted earlier this week
that search was a premises located in
florida belonging to the former
president
the department did not make any public
statements on the day of the search
the former president publicly confirmed
the search that evening
as is his right
copies of both the warrant and the fbi
property receipt were provided on the
day of the search to the former
president's council who was on site
during the search
the search warrant was authorized by a
federal court
upon the required finding of probable
cause
the property receipt is a document that
federal law requires law enforcement
agents to leave with the property owner
the department filed the motion
to make public the warrant and receipt
in light of the former president's
public confirmation of the search
the surrounding circumstances
and the substantial public interest in
this matter
faithful adherence to the rule of law is
the bedrock principle of the justice
department and of our democracy
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly without fear or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing
all americans are tight entitled to the
even-handed application of the law
to due process of the law
and to the presumption of innocence
much of our work is by necessity
conducted out of the public eye
we do that
to protect the constitutional rights of
all americans
and to protect the integrity of our
investigations
federal law
long-standing department rules
and our ethical obligations
prevent me from providing further
details as to the basis of the search at
this time
there are however certain points i want
you to know
first
i personally approve the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter
second the department does not take such
decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means
as an alternative to a search and to
narrowly scope any search that is
undertaken
third
let me address recent unfounded attacks
on the professionalism of the fbi and
justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
the men and women of the fbi and the
justice department are dedicated
patriotic public servants
every day they protect the american
people from violent crime terrorism and
other threats to their safety
while safeguarding our civil rights
they do so at great personal sacrifice
and risk to themselves
i am honored to work alongside them
this is all i can say right now
more information will be made available
in the appropriate way
and at the appropriate time
thank you